recording in progress
live stream started for our LinkedIn
audience
and
waiting for that to get started
foreign
that one more time
yep I see you cigar we will start just a
moment I want to make sure that we're
getting the LinkedIn
stream started correctly
bear with me for just one more moment
okay
all right I'm going to have to proceed
without the LinkedIn stream
unfortunately
is
that's not helping us
so let's get going
and
okay I apologize for that delay
my name is Stuart Creek
I am with simply learned we are the
delivery partner
for uh MIT X pro with the
program
or executive leadership principles
and we'll be talking about that today
We'll be asking you a few questions
about
what's going on
um we'll be asking a few full questions
and
we'll also be asked telling you about
the impact of leadership capabilities
we'll hear a bit from
some of the
lecturers and professors from MIT
and we will then talk about how this
program works how it helps you prepare
for leadership the Technology field
we'll talk about the learner outcomes
that people achieve with this program
and we'll
share with you enrollment steps and then
I'll
take your questions toward the end try
to answer as many as I possibly can
speaking of the
impact
of leadership capabilities
let's hear a little bit from
the folks at MIT
make sure
that we have the sound on for this
[Music]
leadership is about going to a
destination that others haven't been to
yet and Engineering leadership is
fundamentally about changing the
perspective on a problem
technology is the driver of change in
organizations and it's the role of
Technology leadership to anticipate
where is that point of reflection and
what new Direction might we go to
continue our progress
leadership does not have to be the
top-down ego driven way of leading
problem that leadership is about taking
on huge challenges in the world and so
people bring their expertise in as
necessary because this is important work
to do
leadership skills are teachable I'm
convinced that you can train the
techniques and you can train the mindset
let's talk for a second about the
elements of successful leadership if you
don't have influence there's still ways
of persuading people you have to be able
to navigate the three lenses on leading
change
you need to understand who you are and
what you do and do not bring to the
table because as a leader what you want
to do is build a team that complements
the skills that you have leaders are not
in the boardrooms but leaders
making that change and making it viable
and meaningful
engineering leadership today is probably
more than any time in our history what
companies need
and every human being in my view is
designed to be a leader we need to train
to unleash and channel that
[Music]
foreign
okay
I hope that
was audible to everyone
and
I hope that you enjoyed hearing from
some of the lectures and leaders who
will be part of this program
leadership is a force multiplier why is
this important
um this course is especially targeted at
technologists engineers and other people
who have to accomplish
maybe from positions that are not of
authority
and Leadership is the set of skills that
enable you to accomplish your objectives
in concert with others
um
you can't do complex projects
all on your own by definition they
require
more than one individual's effort have
to be coordinated
they have to draw on the required
resources and strengths of team members
and they have to be
organized in a way that the work
proceeds and Beats the constraints of
budget and schedule
so leadership is a set of skills that
allows you to do this
by
employing the resources skills the
talents the drive of other people on
your team
you can learn by leadership skills how
to accomplish these objectives how to
achieve
through influence rather than through
Authority
meaning that you may be on a team you
may be called to lead the team where you
do not have the uh quote unquote
statutory Authority or the
organizational position that allows you
to command other people to do what you
tell them
so you need to be able to to
influence them to do what needs to get
done in a timely fashion for the good of
the project
um
this course focuses on problem-led
leadership
problem-led leadership
looks at how to
create a team and guide it through the
process of solving complex and important
problems nature of the problems that
you're solving
and be part of the leadership strategy
that you use people want
especially in technology Fields people
want to solve complex problems for that
sense of accomplishment
but this is why leadership is important
for people in the technology field
and the the skills the capabilities that
you need to learn
to be able to do this effectively uh
include being able to solve problems
through the methodology of problem-led
lead leadership
to be able to lead change in a positive
way in your organization
be able to be um honest with yourself
about what your
true strengths as a leader are
and to be willing to recognize those
within yourself
to demonstrate leadership capabilities
in the context of technical work
environments which are very different
from
non-problem solving environments where
work has to get done in a
routine fashion
technical work environments in a
problem-solving
mode
have a different
a set of leadership capabilities
required
to create value by aligning your work
processes with the products and
strategies that you're trying to create
and fulfill
to negotiate and manage conflicts
through both
approach of power where you have the
ability at some point to say
I am authorized to do this or through
influence
where you need to be able to say
this is how this benefits both of us
so these approaches in mixing them in
the right balance
extremely important in leadership
finally navigating an organization's
culture and network successfully and
being able to understand
how things get done within your
particular organization what are the
bounds what you can and can't do what
are people naturally aligned to do all
of these skills then together are vital
to leadership
so I want to ask a poll
this poll is
what has stopped you up till now from
enrolling in an executive leadership
program of this type
going to let this run for a few more
moments
okay
as we get
used a little last 10 seconds to answer
the question
and let's show you the answers
so uh
one of the things in my job is I get to
see how these polls come in and this
one's a little unusual for most of the
times we ask questions of this nature
because in this case almost half of the
audience says that the primary
blocker has been
that they don't have time
to complete a program of this find the
time in your schedule to do the work
um usually the what's today's second
lesson here is one of the top two which
is
I can't find a program with a
comprehensive
curriculum that covers everything that
uh I need to learn from this subject and
the third is uh the third place today is
usually also one of the top two which is
don't get the Practical exposure I need
the technical experience with the
subject that will let me demonstrate my
new skills
so
I just wanted to mention that because
schedule is an important factor
and we've designed this program
so that
schedule is less of a concern
the reason is that this program is
delivered entirely online in the space
of
about four months three courses of
three to four weeks each and the time
commitment is about five hours a week
which means that it's something that is
possible to do within almost any
personal schedule work schedule because
the platform is available 24 7. it
allows you to access this information
when you need it now some of the classes
are delivered live and therefore you do
need to be available at those class
meeting times but even if you miss one
of those you can always refer back to
the recording of the class so
uh has great deal of flexibility and
allows you to get
this learning in on your schedule uh in
a way that's convenient for you but it
does have a comprehensive curriculum and
we'll go over that in a minute and it
gives you the ability to do uh Hands-On
Labs simulations case studies that allow
you to practice these skills by doing
so the QR code will take you to the
program homepage on the website but
meantime I'm going to talk to you about
what you get out of the program you get
the professional certificate of
completion
from mitx Pro
which means it has the uh
stamp of approval of Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
it will give you five continuing
education units
which very important for people who are
in fields where either they have
licenses that have to be renewed
have to provide CEUs in support of your
license renewal or if you have an
employer who wants proof that you have
engaged in continuing education to keep
your skill skirt
so
CEUs are valuable
addition to the program
the master classes delivered live online
come from both MIT faculty some of whom
you'll see in the
roster later and also industry experts a
few of whom you saw in the video
including for example the chairman of
uh
this micro device
and
you'll connect with an International
Community of professionals as well so
you'll be learning alongside
other people in the program who've
enrolled from other companies other
Industries you'll have that kind of
exchange of
perspective and knowledge
so this is a great program
and it's delivered through simply
learned from MIT MIT X pro is
the professional education division of
MIT
MIT was founded 160 years ago
it is the home and alma mater of
dozens of Nobel Prize laureates touring
Award winners who are that's the
Computing prize and MacArthur fellows
who are also the MacArthur is also known
as The Genius Grant
MIT is
um
one of the highest concentrations of
brilliant thinkers
researchers and engineers in the world
it has over 60 research centers labs and
programs that work on
solving important problems important
challenges for the world
so MIT Pro on your resume is something
that will be recognized you'll recognize
that
this is a quality program and the
teachings are valuable so
we talk about who should enroll in a
program of this time
so if you're looking to take on greater
responsibilities in your job if you're a
professional and you are trying to move
up
the chain of command within your company
or the
level of responsibility
this is a great program for you
individual contributors and managers who
want to learn how to lead more
effectively and
um
be more productive and efficient
in problem-based leadership so those are
people who can
benefit from this program
and then people who are relatively early
in their science
engineering careers
who want to get a good foundation so
that they can
um
keep their
career track
on track
as they move forward and make sure that
they have the ability to stand out
and Lead their energy
these are the people if you fall into
this category
any one of these three categories this
is a great program for you
well let's ask a second whole question
this whole question is
how much experience do you have in the
workplace this is
are you still in um
University College
or are you in the workforce and if so
how many years have you been in the
workforce
simple question so we won't leave it
open for very long
this is a good time to remind you if you
have questions please put them in the Q
a box
um it'll make it easier for me to find
them when we get to the Q a period as
opposed to scrolling through the chat so
numbers have stopped changing so here's
your answer
and two-thirds of our audience are
people with more than five years of
experience so
this is a great program
or those of you who have more experience
and want
to
um
essentially
Unleash Your Potential
for those of you with zero to five years
experience this as I said is a great
program for foundational
building
and if you're still studying I don't
think that there's a prerequisite
of having to have a degree but it's
certainly a valuable thing to have for
this program so let's move forward
did I share those results with you
but moving forward
how do the program prepare you
program consists of four courses each
course
calendar duration of about a month
and it consists of three to four weeks
of classes
and covers a particular concentration
within leadership
Foundation is understanding
organizational strategy and capabilities
knowing what your organization wants to
accomplish and what tools it has to
accomplish those goals with
course two is negotiating implying
influence and Power
being able to exercise leadership and
motivate people to share in your vision
and help make it reality
navigating culture and leveraging
culture and networks is the third course
and that's understanding how to
negotiate through uh your organization's
particular style
culture traditions and um
structure
and finally course four is focused on
you and your leadership strengths what
they are
that are particular to you and how to
um
apply them and
use them for the greatest
possible effect
of course one breaks down into four
weeks of strategy
understanding corporate strategy
organizational strategy product
what it is that you're trying to
accomplish
build
capability work and dynamic work design
and
this is a week that focuses on the
different models of how work is
organized
and week four focuses on Dynamic work
design as a strategy or method for you
to um
achieve problem solving work more
efficiently
course two
three weeks negotiation
influence and Power
and again these are three aspects of how
to
get people to do what you need them to
do in order to achieve the Project's
goal
this is uh
three different
aspects of leadership and you need to
understand how each works and when is
the right time to apply it
course three navigating and leveraging
culture and networks
again understanding the culture of your
organization
what are its social
traditions
what are its values
what are the boundaries
or uh Beyond which you shouldn't go
within your organization then talking
about networks and how
people interact within the organization
what are the power structures what are
the support structures who do you need
to talk to to get things done
and then the change management
simulation
is a great exercise where
you go through the process of
change management in a simulated
business environment
so that you can practice these skills
and understand how
to
influence or Implement change within a
given culture
finally the
module on your own leadership
strengths
looking at your self-inventory of what
your strengths are
and establishing and implementing your
vision for how you want to lead in
future
both your immediate situation but also
as a leadership style ongoing
those are the four courses
and I'm going to share this with you
about how these courses are delivered
that's what MIT has chosen simply
learning to help with
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep
tracking your progress every step of the
way we'll help you stay on plan with
automated and 24 7 human support at the
core of our programs are our live
virtual classrooms where you interact
Real Time with trainers that are
recognized leaders in their field there
you'll review key Concepts get questions
answered and interact with your peers
the important reports on the audience if
you notice are demographics this is
super useful especially if you're
running ads for example you control it
on social media later you'll learn
social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category show your
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes at
ask your questions to top industry
leaders in exclusive ask me anything
sessions so uh there's another
interesting question on the chat box and
say that oh to optimize in YouTube you
can use the rising session of Google
Trends and optimize it okay so let's go
back to here right here where it says
web searches and you can see that
there's going to be the YouTube searches
okay so now you can see that the YouTube
searches is going to be so there's a
option uh under not just web search and
they respond to be a YouTube search okay
so just go ahead and click on YouTube
search and you should be able to
optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
refer to when we come across any sort of
original video
apps would appear within those video
content so you would be caught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right
so that gives you an idea of how the
platform works and what the environment
is that you'll be in when you're
actually listening to
um and watching the materials and taking
the live master classes it's all done
through that same interface
that all gives you the ability to track
where you are in the program at any
given time and
what your progress is and it
keeps track of
how far you've gone so that you can earn
credit toward that final certificate
and the faculty and instructors who are
part of this program include Dr Crawley
Dr Nino
Dr Penning Dr suskin
Dr famana and Dr Reagan so you can see
that these come out of different
departments within MIT and the MIT uh
lung School of Management
they look at uh
both Technical and Engineering
backgrounds such as Dr Crowley and
Department of Aeronautics and
astronautics
um and Dr Nino and the engineering
leadership program they also look at
organizational behavior and
System Dynamics for example from Dr
repenning
um the organizational studies from Dr
Vin man and so these
individuals are going to be the the
people delivering the material to you
along with representatives from industry
um got a bit of a flavor for that from
the video from MIT
so
we look at the learner profile
and some of the reviews of Learners who
have completed this program
we have a
Lisa who is from the
Boeing Company she says I like the cases
it really helped me better understand
the concepts the content's highly
related to my daily work provides A New
Perspective of the relationships
inside my organization
Emily Wright who is another technologist
from Boeing who has a
High Praise for the program an awesome
program for emerging leaders
for those currently in leadership
positions the knowledge tools and
techniques are very useful to companies
worldwide and I would highly recommend
this program to all levels of employees
finally Edward Alston who is at Boeing
UK really enjoyed how the role play
aspects of this course gave me an
opportunity to try some of the things
we've learned
I've been lucky to have a great group of
people my team has made negotiations fun
and interesting so that highlights the
fact that this program relies on
exercises projects case studies that
allow you to practice the skills as you
learn them
So based on what we've said so far today
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
we just launched that question and leave
it open for about 20 25 seconds
I'll leave it open for about another 10
seconds
go
five four three
two one
and 75 percent of our audience said that
they are interested in
taking this program so let me share with
you
the enrollment steps
they're very straightforward
you start by contacting ask us at
simplylearn.net
which
will get you to our learning Consultants
who will help you with getting enrolled
in the program they'll take basic
information about you ask you some
questions about your level of interest
and commitment to learning about
executive leadership principles
um it's important to us and to MIT Pro X
pro that you have the commitment
both financially but also in terms of
the time and the effort that you're
going to put in because
don't want
somebody to enroll
and then find out that they're just not
as interested as they thought they were
so
we do to do that level of evaluation and
if you pass that we will send you the
admission offer
Mission offer will let you get started
it started
pretty much on a rotating schedule
um
you'll want to contact ask us at
simplylearn.net in order
to find out when the next
class cohort starts but they start
regularly
I'm going to put the
email address into the chat along with
the URL for our program page
here
foreign
there you go
you have the email address available in
the chat as long as as well as the uh
URL for the program page
well you say financing available as low
as 286 dollars a month you'll you will
want to contact ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out what the
total program cost is
but we structured it so that
should be affordable to you
so
based on what you've heard if you are
still interested how soon would you want
to enroll
and I think the numbers are slowing down
so we'll give you another five seconds
to get your answers in
three
two one
so about half of our audience are
looking at something more than six
months out from now but
um
around a third of the audience a little
more than a quarter at least are
interested in starting immediately or
within the next three months so for
everybody
um in the webinar who is interested in
doing this
sooner or later please contact us at ask
us simplylearn.net if you're planning to
do it soon you'll want to get your last
questions answered find out the uh
fees and
get lined up to enroll if you're looking
to do it six months or more out you'll
still want to be in touch with us over
time so it's good to contact learning
consultants get your questions answered
and have the knowledge you need in order
to
proceed when it's right for you
but with that I am going to go to
questions and answers
again I apologize for like don't get to
your ones from the chat
but it's a lot easier for me to hit the
question and answer
uh proof of participation for this
webinar we do not
generally provide proof of participation
for
the webinars we put on to discuss
programs
um apologize for that we do provide
proof of participation for webinars that
uh
deal with uh technical subjects
career Fields
other information of that type of thing
so if we uh we're going to give you an
overview of
um
project management field and what uh
what trends are happening that would be
a webinar we would give
proof of participation
what are the enrollment fees of the
program again I've got
underneath the monthly cost so I would
ask you to contact ask us at
simplywhere.net
and direct that question to them
copul asks the benefit of the program
benefit of the program popular is that
this is going to
um
give you the tools that you can use in
your career in order to um
be in a more effective leader take more
responsibility of over
projects within your company
to get more accomplished
and to stand out frankly from your peers
in the um the eyes of your management as
an effective
team leader and somebody with potential
to move up in the chain of management so
um
Kalyan points out that you will get a
recording of this
webinar so you'll be able to review this
information
um
we have a question about are the
instructors teaching the classes from
MIT the answer to that is yes for this
program
um you will get uh instruction from MIT
professors and instructors you'll also
get the master classes from professors
instructors and also industry experts
brought in from outside so
um
I've got a lot of Rich content
and
uh are there discounts available I uh
for people attending this meeting
um I don't have the answer to that but
please do contact us at simply learn.net
um I was not informed that there would
be so apologize for that uh is there job
assistance abroad Apple this uh
particular program does not include a
job assistance component
either within the U.S or abroad to
apologize for that but um
this is a
different style program some of our
uh
postgraduate programs University aligned
boot camps and that type of thing do
have a
element of
job assistance that continues on after
the boot camp this is not unfortunately
one of those
so
um let me take a quick look through the
chat to see if I can find any questions
what is the assessment process
aravindra the assessment process of this
program includes
he was online assessment
for each module
so as you complete the work for the week
you have
reviews and then when you complete each
course there's an assessment to make
sure that you've covered and grasped the
material
uh
question uh you simply learn part of MIT
no uh simply learned as an independent
company and
we are one of the world's
largest and leading providers of online
professional education especially around
technology and the digital economy
um
we partner with universities like MIT
Purdue Caltech University of Texas at
Austin
we
provide
our platform as a means for them to
deliver their content
along with our delivery method so uh
while we run a number of courses of Our
Own
which are simply learned branded
products we also provide this type of
Cooperative collaborative process with
universities where we
act as their delivery partner
I hope that answers that question
okay
and
are the four modules mandatory
or can we choose any module and the the
answer to that is the four modules are
mandatory
or modules that comprise the program
um
is this a blend from PMP this is not a
PMP program this is a leadership program
and
I think that covers
questions I can see in our stream so
Prasad simpi we simply learn is an
online company that is to say that we
deliver all of our training online
that's available to a worldwide audience
and
one of the benefits of that is it's also
available to you on 24 7 on your own
schedule
than the last
is the program beneficial for mechanical
engineering careers and the answer to
that is yes this program that is
valuable in all engineering
um research scientific Fields
um these are skills that you can use in
all of those areas
in problem solving and
leading projects programs so
that I'm going to
include
and we will move on to
that last question for you in the
audience
that is
uh if you are interested in enrollment
do you need assistance
and we help you
so
let's ask this quick question
I'll leave this open for another
10 seconds as people get their answers
in
and
five four three two one
oh
and about a third of the audience said
yes so again please
contact us
through
ask us at simplylearn.net
get that done for you
but with that I want to thank everyone
who's attended today's webinar
um we are
looking forward to welcoming you into
the MIT X pro learning community
and
thank you for the time and I will put
into the chat one last time so that it's
right at your fingertips
the
link to the program page as well as
the email address
here we go
and if a reminder from Kalyan who says
happy Republic Day so
if you happen to be attending from India
happy Republic Day
with that
include the webinar so thank you again
and we look forward to seeing you in our
learner pool